number six
moving on uh her friends they can be
your biggest obstacle or can gift
wrapper and server to you on a silver
platter explain that
well like i was saying when you go to a
group of girls there's always
you know the one mother hand she always
kind of runs the crew right
um she can make or break whether it's a
good or bad name that's the same thing
at these private apartments right
if there are these girls looking to step
outside the relationship and kind of
like alpha the crew
that's it it's going for it but if you
rub her the wrong way
no one's going home with you i had a
night where
i was this one girl was all over me very
beautiful girl
and her friends kind of the bigger you
know less attractive one
looks like hey she's got a boyfriend you
gotta leave her be
and i'm oh that's cool it's cool you
know it's just part of the show and i
started talking to her
and i started asking she's got a
boyfriend everything like that because i
could tell she wanted me instead and i
said well hey i got a buddy who's single
i get my buddy over there not only did
she hook up with my buddy
she encouraged her friend to dump her
boyfriend and go home with me
so the girl she's originally saying no
because now now it's the balls and her
gordon's go into her favor
well i guess that makes a big difference
you know well
at least she has a decency to dump him
right yeah
um you know and that's something i
always say too with my experience as a
dancer um
these guys would get dumped by girls so
unless the guy cheated did something
stupid to justify a breakup
that he's trying to get her to forgive
she's dumping him because she's already
on to another guy
and she's already been with another guy
for a long time i always tell these guys
don't go back to your girl because i
don't know how many times
i've had these girls you know they have
boyfriends they hook up with one of the
dancers
and now they're telling the guy hey i'm
not into anymore it's not working out
they don't say hey i just cheated on you
say
it's not working out and this guy's
chasing her pouring his heart out to her
trying to get her back
and then when she realizes that fanny's
fantasies not happening anymore she's
right back to him it doesn't say she's
had you know chad plowed through her a
couple times
yeah i find that hilarious when women
are just like oh it's not you it's
you know it's just me meanwhile guys
like magic mike are rearranging her
insides
uh and then sending her home in the
morning right um
what kind of uh notch count did you rack
up doing doing this
job um it's pretty high
um i won't say wilt chamberlain but uh
you